احلام في ليلتها الماسيه اما الجديد في
حياه جورج وسوف تشخيص مؤلم لحاله بروس
والصدر يحذر من معاويه اليكم الابرز في
اسبوع
[موسيقى]
تحيه الفنانه الاماراتيه احلام حفلا
جماهريا في الرياض بعنوان الليله الماسيه
حقق تفاعلا على منصات التواصل في المملكه
الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
احلام اطلت على الجمهور باقراط ضخمه وصفت
بالثريا نالت نصيبا وافرا من تعليقات
المتفاعلين مع الحفل
[موسيقى]
وعلى سيره الحفلات من المقرر ان يعود
سلطان الطرب جورج وسوف لممارسه نشاطه
الفني بحفل سيحييه في الكويت خلال مارس
اذار المقبل وذلك بعد انقضاء فتره الحداد
على ابنه الراحل وديع الذي اهداه في عيد
الحب اغنيه نصف عمري بمناسبه 40 يوما على
وفاته وشهد هذا اليوم ولاده اول احفاده
عمياء من ابنه جورج جونير وحققت الصوره
التي نشرها ابو وديع وهو يحتضن حفيدته
تفاعلا كبيرا من محبي السلطان على منصات
التواصل في العالم العربي
[موسيقى]
عالميا اعلنت عائله بروس ان الممثل مصاب
بنوع من الخلف يسمى الخرف الجبهي الصدغي
وذلك في بيان مشترك لعائله النجم البالغ
من العمر 67 عاما قالت فيه ان الاخبار
مؤلمه الى انه من المريح الحصول على تشخيص
واضح في النهايه وتابع البيان اليوم لا
توجد علاجات لهذا المرض حقيقه نامل ان
يحصل ذلك في السنوات المقبله وقال البيان
الذي تلقت سي ان ان نسخه منه انه مع تقدم
حاله بروس نامل ان يركز اي اهتمام اعلامي
على تسليط الضوء على هذا المرض الذي يحتاج
الى مزيد من الوعي والبحث وكانت عائله
ويليس قد كشفت عن تشخيصه للحبس الكلاميه
في عام 2022 وقل في ذلك الوقت انه كان
يعاني من حاله طبيه تؤثر على قدراته
المعرفيه وسوف ياخذ استراحه من التمثيل
عالميا ايضا افتتح مهرجان برلين السينمائي
فعاليات دولته 73 في العاصمه الالمانيه
الخميس الماضي بزخم كبير من الافلام
المعروضه والحضور مقارنه بالدورتين
السابقتين وعبر الكثير منهم عن دعمهم
لاحتجاجات ايران على السجاده الحمراء كما
تحدث الرئيس الاوكراني عبر الفيديو في حفل
الافتتاح حيث يتضامن المهرجان ايضا مع
اوكرانيا التي يعرض عنها عده افلام ومنها
الفيلم الوثائقي قوه خارقه من اخراج شومب
بن وتستمر فعاليات المهرجان الى السادس
والعشرين من فبراير الجاري
واخيرا وكما الموسم الماضي بدا جدل عروض
موسم دراما رمضان مبكرا مع دعوه زعيم
التيار الصدري في العراق مقتدى الصدر الى
عدم بث مسلسل درامي عن سيره معاويه بن ابي
سفيان مؤسس الدوله الامويه وقال الصدر في
تغريده نشرها عبر حسابه الرسمي على تويتر
بما معناه انه يرى من الاجدر والافضل بل
للمتعين ان تتراجع قناه ام بي سي عن بث
المسلسل ويحمل المسلسل توقيع المخرج طارق
العريان ويجسد شخصيه معاويه الممثل السوري
لجين اسماعيل الذي سبق وان جسد شخصيه محي
الدين ابن عربي في مسلسل مقامات العشق
وهذه ليست المره الاولى التي يتم فيها
تجسيد شخصيه معاويه بن ابي سفيان دراميا
حيث لعب دوره الفنان السوري رشيد عساف في
مسلسل الحسن والحسين الذي عرض في موسم
دراما 2011 واثار جدلا مماثلا في ذلك
الوقت